其他人：这是什么
Others: What's this?
Lucia: 这个是我的那个是
Lucia: This is my... that is...
Tasha: 这是什么啊
Tasha: What is this?
Katrina: 嗯还是预制菜香啊
Katrina: Hmm, pre-made dishes still taste the best.
Shure: 老北京就爱吃预制菜是吗
Shure: So, old Beijingers love pre-made dishes, right?
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Katrina: 鸡蛋
Katrina: Egg.
其他人：鸡蛋糕
Others: Egg cake.
Tasha: 鸡蛋糕
Tasha: Egg cake.
Lucia: 没事我站着吧
Lucia: It's okay, I'll stand.
其他人：你怎么那么快就吃完了
Others: How did you finish eating so fast?
其他人：你吃这拌饭是预制菜啊
Others: Are you eating pre-made dishes with rice?
其他人：肯定预制菜
Others: Definitely pre-made dishes.
其他人：没有理由不是
Others: No reason it wouldn't be.
其他人：老烧鸡不是预制菜
Others: Old roasted chicken isn't pre-made dishes.
其他人：更是
Others: Even more so.
其他人：老烧鸡不是预制菜
Others: Old roasted chicken isn't pre-made dishes.
Katrina: 喂
Katrina: Hey.
其他人：不是的
其他人：他发红包了
Others: He sent a red envelope.
其他人：啊啊
Others: Ah, ah.
Katrina: 好的我去拿一下
Katrina: Okay, I'll go get it.
Katrina: 谢谢
Katrina: Thanks.
Shure: 就我们仨饿了是不是
Shure: Are we the only three who are hungry?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
其他人：那你站起来
Others: Then stand up.
Shure: 我就嘴上说说
Shure: I'm just saying.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Shure: 你还当真你这
Shure: You actually took it seriously.
Shure: 还真是云老
Shure: You're really naive.
Shure: 跟你客气两下
Shure: Just being polite.
Shure: 你滚出去
Shure: Get out.
其他人：这不怕你心里过不去
Others: Don't worry about it.
Shure: 吃完饭就要开始做蛋糕
Shure: After eating, we need to start making the cake.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
其他人：伙伴
Others: Partner.
Shure: 我的伙伴
Shure: My partner.
Shure: 应该还有一个小时就到了
Shure: Should be here in about an hour.
Jake:你的什么伙伴
Jake: What partner?
Shure: 我的
Shure: My...
其他人：兄弟们
Others: Guys
Shure: 女性伙伴
Shure: Female partners
其他人：这个是干什么的这个
Others: What's this for?
其他人：装饰的
Others: It's for decoration
其他人：卧槽
Others: Whoa
其他人：独眼
Others: One-eyed
Jake:眼睛没了
Jake: The eye is gone
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's over
Shure: 你这是正版的吗
Shure: Is this the original?
其他人：是正版 399
Others: Yeah, it's the original, 399
Shure: 3块9毛93999
Shure: 3.99? 3999?
Jake:然后包邮啊
Jake: And with free shipping
Shure: 还有弹窗
Shure: And pop-ups too
其他人：官方买的啥东西
Others: What did you buy from the official store?
Shure: 华强北官方买的
Shure: Bought from Huaqiangbei official
其他人：苹果店官方买的
Others: Bought from the Apple store official
Shure: 华强北不是在全县吗
Shure: Isn't Huaqiangbei all over the county?
Shure: 在南京吗
Shure: It's in Nanjing?
Jake:华强南
Jake: Huaqiangnan
其他人：不要我花钱我就买
Others: I don't care, as long as I buy it
其他人：华强南
Others: Huaqiangnan
其他人：修硕那个眼镜为什么进度条那么慢呢
Others: Shure, why is the progress bar so slow on your glasses?
Jake:他眼镜确实慢他那个通信不太好
Jake: His glasses are indeed slow, the connection isn't great
其他人：我以为它断了
Others: I thought it broke
Jake:总有一个慢的
Jake: There's always one that's slow
Jake:很不巧就是他
Jake: Unfortunately, it's his
Jake:修硕这个慢
Jake: Shure's is slow
Jake:反正无所谓哈哈
Jake: Anyway, it doesn't matter, haha
Jake:夜里面隔两小时起来
Jake: Waking up every two hours at night
Jake:看一看我靠
Jake: Checking, dang
Jake:还没好就断了
Jake: Not done yet, it broke
其他人：你那天导IP的时候大概什么速度啊
Others: What was the speed when you transferred the IP that day?
其他人：10几兆每秒
Others: About 10 MB per second
其他人：不是80吗
Others: Wasn't it 80?
其他人：后来又有一些新装备是吗
Others: Did you get new equipment later?
其他人：就不就是你带的那个
Others: Wasn't it the one you brought?
其他人：又 戴了
Others: Wore it again
Jake:这个装备
Jake: This equipment
其他人：有的读卡器80兆有的读卡器就15兆
Others: Some card readers are 80 MB, some are 15 MB
Shure: 你可以试试苹果自带的那个
Shure: You can try the built-in Apple one
其他人：苹果那个是最快的
Others: The Apple one is the fastest.
Shure: 嗯那为什么不用那个呢
Shure: Yeah, so why not use that one?
其他人：那我们移动硬盘没
Others: But we don't have a portable hard drive.
其他人：嗯
Others: Hmm.
其他人：其实也可以
Others: Actually, we could.
其他人：还好吧没带
Others: It's okay, didn't bring it.
Shure: 我那有一个SSD
Shure: I have an SSD.
其他人：SSD固态啊
Others: SSD, solid state?
其他人：可以啊
Others: Sure, that works.
其他人：最后一天了不早说
Others: It's the last day, why didn't you say earlier?
Shure: 没人问我啊
Shure: No one asked me.
Shure: 这有没有可能这个月
Shure: Is there any chance this month?
Tasha: 有自愿者
Tasha: There are volunteers.
Katrina: 到现在都没有排练过一遍
Katrina: We haven't rehearsed even once up to now.
Katrina: 这个批人改成乐队了
Katrina: This group turned into a band.
其他人：那我那天不是白练了吗
Others: So I practiced for nothing that day?
Katrina: 你可以那个solo哈哈
Katrina: You could do a solo, haha.
其他人：那不必了
Others: No need for that.
Katrina: 就算改成唱歌了
Katrina: Even if it turned into singing,
Katrina: 到现在也没有合过一遍
Katrina: We still haven't practiced together once.
Katrina: 想一下
Katrina: Think about it.
Katrina: 嗯晴天和那个new boy
Katrina: Hmm, "Sunny Day" and "New Boy".
Katrina: 所以今天下午大概多少个人
Katrina: So how many people are there this afternoon?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: No idea.
Katrina: 呵呵呵
Katrina: Hehehe.
Jake:对真不知道啊
Jake: Really, no idea.
Katrina: 因为你那个甜点的分量不是要那个
Katrina: Because the quantity of your dessert needs to be...
Jake:那个没关系他他就是
Jake: It doesn't matter, we'll just
Jake:我们就看剩多少就吃多少
Jake: see how much is left and eat that.
Lucia: 所以现在
Lucia: So now...
Katrina: 你一个你一个我一个
Katrina: You one, you one, I one.
Katrina: 你有几个朋友两个
Katrina: How many friends do you have? Two.
Lucia: 两个
Lucia: Two.
Katrina: 修硕一个
Katrina: Shure, one.
其他人：20人
Others: 20 people.
Jake:15
Jake: 15.
其他人：就算上咱工作人员
Others: Including our staff.
Jake:嗯15搁人
Jake: Yeah, 15 people.
Katrina: 234 微微几个
Katrina: 234, how many for Tasha?
Jake:薇薇可能没有
Jake: Tasha might not have anyone.
Jake:可能没有算她一个吧
Jake: Maybe she wasn't counted.
其他人：在可控范围内
Others: It's within control.
Katrina: 那就是6
Katrina: So that makes 6.
Katrina: 我们一共几个人
Katrina: How many of us are there in total?
Katrina: 那真的确实不需要排练随便吧
Katrina: Then we really don't need to rehearse, just wing it.
Katrina: 我现在已经快被改造成功了
Katrina: I'm almost successfully transformed now.
Katrina: 这一人改造计划变成p
Katrina: This one-person transformation plan is now...
Lucia: 我要是还在本科就好了
Lucia: I wish I was still an undergrad.
Lucia: 我可以把我舍友都呼朋引伴的
Lucia: I could invite all my roommates.
Lucia: 拉来吃甜点
Lucia: To come and eat dessert.
Lucia: 我们都特爱吃甜食
Lucia: We all love sweets.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake:这人今天早上8点就到我们起床
Jake: This person was up by 8 AM, before we even got up.
Jake:很牛逼
Jake: Impressive.
Katrina: 他说反话呢呵呵
Katrina: He's being sarcastic, haha.
Katrina: 唉你今天几点起的
Katrina: Hey, what time did you get up today?
Jake:额九点
Jake: Uh, nine o'clock.
Lucia: 结果睡太晚没睡好
Lucia: Ended up sleeping too late and didn't sleep well.
Katrina: 太爽了这床
Katrina: This bed is too comfy.
Katrina: 我闹钟也是8点
Katrina: My alarm was set for 8.
Katrina: 然后10点半醒
Katrina: Then I woke up at 10:30.
Jake:四点多睡的
Jake: Went to bed around 4.
Jake:就醒一次
Jake: Woke up just once.
Jake:昨天注册了货币
Jake: Registered for crypto yesterday.
其他人：那你们搞搞好了吗
Others: Did you get it sorted out?
Jake:晚上炒股了
Jake: Traded stocks last night.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
其他人：一开始充了80美刀
Others: Initially added 80 dollars.
其他人：今天早上涨了
Others: It went up this morning.
Jake:哦以太币涨了
Jake: Oh, Ethereum went up.
Katrina: 我朋友还带了吉他来
Katrina: My friend even brought a guitar.
其他人：是吗嗯
Others: Really? Hmm.
Katrina: 我不知道
Katrina: I didn't know.
Katrina: 他带的电吉他还是带的那个吉他
Katrina: Did he bring an electric guitar or a regular guitar?
其他人：真好嗯嗯嗯
Others: That's great. Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Katrina: 果然让他solo哈哈哈
Katrina: Let him do a solo, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈只吃边上的饭
Katrina: Haha, just eating the edges of the meal.
Katrina: 吃吃困了睡一觉再醒来吃
Katrina: Eat, get sleepy, take a nap, wake up, and eat again.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 淡淡的让他们自己过来做甜点吧
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: 好客之道哈哈
Katrina: 哈
Jake:大家注意
Lucia: 可今天晚上过完我朋友就不再收费了
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Jake:我们给他们准备了很多原料
Katrina: 今天变成体验了
Jake:是的
其他人：喂你车被刮蹭了
其他人：在打电话呢
其他人：我在这屋里边吃饭
Jake:那个车费你们开几辆车
其他人：那其实是一辆
Jake:好结束吧我们来导一下